اوكرانيا تصف تولي روسيا رئاسه مجلس الامن
الدولي بالعار حسب تغريده على موقع تويتر
لاندريه مكتب الرئيس الاوكراني
ليس مجرد عار انها ضربه رمزيه اخرى لنظام
العلاقات الدوليه القائمه على القواعد
الكرملين قال من جهته انه يخطط لممارسه
جميع الحقوق في اثناء تولي المنصب وكانت
روسيا تبنت الجمعه استراتيجيه جديده في
السياسه الخارجيه تصنف الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه والدول الغربيه على انها تهديد
وجودي لموسكو ينبغي عليها ان تحارب هيمنته
البيت الابيض اعتبر من جهته على لسان
المتحدث باسمه ان روسيا لسوء الحظ عضوا
دائما في مجلس الامن ولا يوجد مسار قانوني
دولي عملي لتغيير هذا الواقع
نتوقع ان تواصل روسيا استخدام مقعدها في
المجلس لنشر معلومه مضلله ومحاوله صرف
الانتباه عما تقوم به وتبرير افعالها في
اوكرانيا وجرائم الحرب التي يرتكبها عناصر
قواتها والانتهاك السافر للقانون ولميثاق
الامم المتحده ان الدوله التي تنتهك بشكل
سارخ ميثاق الامم المتحده وتغزو جارتها
ليس لها مكان في مجلس الامن الدولي الرئيس
الفرنسي منويل اتهم الجمعه روسيا بانها
سمحت بل شجعت قواتها على ارتكاب جرائم حرب
في اوكرانيا وذلك في الذكرى السنويه
الاولى لاستعاده كييف السيطره على مدينه
بوتشا التي اصبحت رمزا لهذه الجرائم يعود
تاريخ اخر مره تولت فيها موسكو الرئاسه
الدوريه لمجلس الام ن الدولي الى شهر شباط
فبراير من عام 2022 الذي بدات في الرابع
والعشرين منه غزوها الشامل للاراضي
الاوكرانيه